welcome to winners on Wednesday our
muscle leads and I'm joined this week by
an incredibly inspirational guy
this story will blow you away his name
is Declan parcel and they're definitely
very very good to have you on the show
what's happening there is no prom at all
now your story is it's pretty incredible
so what I'm going start off from the
beginning you when you were in the
Marines
yeah so my background is something to
Joe like a true marine I've spent 10
years yeah and in the wrong Marines and
I've left just a couple months ago and
you join there when you're 18 glowing I
was 18 yeah so straight out school let's
go
this man levels straight experience were
Marines I've had a great time and
traveled all over the place
Norway not to warfare over there I spent
some time in Afghanistan run Middle East
and some diving expeditions security at
the Olympics yeah all sorts it's been a
crazy minute if you learn a lot and grow
a lot as a person you think while you're
over there yeah both physically and
mentally
you know and it does definitely sort
toughen you up plans some push you
through some challenging situations yeah
now while you're over there you injured
your shoulder yeah so about four years
ago I this was in a proper tournament
for the military for the Marines and
when it for Otago and dislocated and
I've had two operations since and I'm
fortunate enough that my career in the
Marines could no longer continue unless
I wanted to take an office job which is
just more not for me no okay so you in
the Marines you've been there for 10
years
yeah your whole life it was military
yeah how did it feel to come out of that
it's been a bit of a shock to the system
to be fair sort of you go from being
around a load of those guys and your
friends you know that you kind of you
know bonding with to actually being been
on your own
even after two months now but I'm still
sort of Justin I mean it's been a
relatively sort of easy transition
because of them know what I'm doing in
property yeah yeah okay so you come out
the Marines and you think I want to do
property yeah what what made you what
made you think you want to do doctor I
know I want to do property but when I
started off it was I had no real
intention of going in full-time I hadn't
heard of any sort of training facilities
or Samuel or or as YouTube channel yeah
I literally bought my first property in
October 2017 purely to living up in
Liverpool and you know my girlfriend was
going to move in with me and bought how
to leave a lot of work doing some it it
was a repossession and brave well I
didn't get survey done which was yeah
maybe not my brightest idea where did
you get the money from for this I saved
through my time in the military you know
yeah and go away a lot so it was
relatively easy when you're away to put
a bit of money aside when you're on ship
yeah and things like that but did you
put the sea pour all your money into
this property yeah I think I put deposit
down yeah what my initially my own
property put the 10% deposit down and I
started doing up but because I've been
getting sober done I realized that we
had a bit dumb but driver under the
stairs
oh no and then there was a leak in the
roof and I remember my mum can around
and saying Declan what what have you
bought around Christmastime and I
literally bought the what of the work
well it seemed like yeah a bag of
spammers if you like so you start doing
it started doing it up yeah and quite
soon the the initial bit of money that
I'd put aside got blown up blowing up
the water and before that I was 2 3
credit cards maxed out yeah so you've
got this house yeah that's horrible yeah
you've flown all your savings on it
everything
are you living in it at this point I
understood not living in that it's still
not in a position to live in it put all
your money on it it's still not even fit
to living in there unfortunately
okay yeah that's pretty bad it's bad and
then these things took a slightly even
worse turn in the beginning of 2018 but
that was rushed into a school and he
wasn't wasn't well for a while and when
he was at my I was going to the hospital
he had loads of medication and you know
it's quite proud man and he knew that me
and my brother were off working in Devon
in them in the military heatless backing
Ken and I was growing up to Liverpool
and doing stuff for the house and got a
phone call from my brother saying they
got into hospital and yeah unfortunately
we lost him ten days later
yeah it's prostate cancer so in the end
he made it no that's that's fine and and
there was there was a thing that's kind
of why I'm sore in property now
full-time and that and then discovering
Samuel so he said to me while Steve went
where was this so when was this this was
in February this year yeah this year so
in February this year you just come out
the ministry I'm still in the military
so they know at this point yeah it's
something actually trying to juggle a
house refurb mine one in Liverpool and
then sort of see everything that can
grow and grow into a whole a little bit
and down and spent a couple weeks my
dad's before we lost it but before
before we lost him and he said to me in
hospital that he was always looking
forward to retirement and he was never
well enough to do anything with it so he
retired at 65 and then we lost him four
years later and that you know that sort
of really ground Holman to me you know
it was a bit of a well I mean you're
like falling apart weights yeah it was a
better that time and you know and
shortly after that I feel what am i
doing with this with this property and
that's when I started reading books on
property and okay
across the summer leads by diagram hi
Ivan hi and it was like a lot of stuff
in that book run run to me how so so
many people they they were carved 99% of
us work hardens over 65 to then retire
on 40% of what we can afford to live on
in the first place and you know my daddy
he worked hard he was a long-distance
lorry driver I'd leave on a Sunday night
work all week and then come back on a
Friday and you know he really tried to
look after me and my brother and that's
what his dad did before and before him
and that's what he knew and that was the
way that life worked and and I thought
you know there's gotta be there's gotta
be another way and then I didn't hurry
I didn't hurry a little bit money from
him and I was like I'm gonna make this
work you know mr. generate and heritage
30,000 for me okay so that helped me out
a little bit with with the money but one
of the videos that I remember watching
on there on the YouTube channel was
don't don't buy where you live then
where you live yeah and then buy to rent
so you know I rang up and my mortgage
advisor and I said to him I said this
was the point now this was the point
where you started to educate yourself
educating you realizing what so I know
that you've obviously read samuelosborne
yes you're watching the YouTube channels
yeah which everything don't you meet you
out on the property investors crash
course of course you're learning this
stuff now this is what I love so much
about about this story is that you're in
such a hard is it I mean this is only
what 10 tablets are filming it's about
ten months of their sort of seminars yes
so this is you know such a horrible
situation you've lost your dad you've
bought this property that's a disaster
you've got no savings left do in a
really horrible situation and the way
that you learn and the way that you've
educated yourself and turned it around
is just incredible so the first thing
what the first thing that you
about was a strategy called by
refurbishment financed by refurbish
refinance so I bought a property and I
was refurb anair yeah inadvertently
because you know I wanted to put my own
stamp on this property and it was a big
deal because it had a lot of a lot of
stuff to me don't say yeah massively
underestimated the refurb cost yeah and
it spells every other ways rang up my
broker and it's been in the game like 20
years you gotta go his property and I
said swim you know pass the read in some
moves but can I read finances and he was
like well we have to wait six months
okay so but yeah we can get the lender
out and they gave me a further advance
and so I bought the property for 92y a
10% deposit and then I spent let's say
where I would have 16,000 17,000 refurb
so it's 107 and then it got really bad
at 135 how awesome is that
I mean it's it blind didn't even get a
survey there on it for yourself to live
in and then you've managed to buy
refurbished refinancing we didn't even
know that we'd ever know about it didn't
even know about sand hill across this so
how much money did you pull out of it
soak up all that 28,000 I have to leave
15% they wanted me to leave 15% in the
property yeah so I started with 11 grand
sort of deposit spend 16 17 mereta all
my money back
that is incredible yeah that is inside
so that was obviously greater than
obviously what some you said in his book
about you know rent when your own house
or what rent where you live and then buy
to sort of run out yeah so I spoke to my
broker and I said you know I mean I'm in
the Marines and down in Devon Monday to
Friday my circumstances you know have
changed somewhat can we look to get
permission from the lender to rent my
house out and he's grabbed all that away
for me and lo and behold I thought this
property would actually work quite well
as a multi that yeah it's quite close to
the city centre you know great for young
professionals or students yeah
I was littler maybe in the student
market students wouldn't start until
September so in someone's book he
mentions about other structured property
strategies like the service to
combination with it so you know room now
and happy and being to conduct on etc so
I we had the Grand National coming up in
in Liverpool around April time and I
remember people saying they cannot get
accommodation for love nor money so I
might be onto something here
so I like drastically Fran small beds
bit fell furniture nothing you know most
of it was sort of second hands and
mattresses took a few photos put on
Airbnb and I got a booking for the
Friday night effort a Saturday night and
over that weekend it was it's nine
hundred pounds so I depends how many
pounds for a weekend for from my house
and I at the time was doing all the
cleaning or the laundry for the first
month
yeah I read this hold on you were doing
the cleaning so I travel up from from
Devon on the Friday I believe work about
one o'clock and then I get to the
property this is for all of April I
would and stripped of the beds clean the
house and top to bottom
quite often we'd have someone had left
on the Sunday or Monday and and then I
go and clean it and then I remember the
grand national weekend was the worst cuz
I actually went to the national on the
Saturday but on the Friday we had people
that went to ladies days so they were
checking out Saturday and I had another
group of Laos checking in Saturday
what's Diamond is like wanting to go to
the National so I turned up to the house
eleven o'clock clean lit from top to
bottom some of the lads are still asleep
they made a mess and and then I made it
to the national and unfortunately I got
some good reviews from from the poverty
for it was an eventful month and
unfortunately at the end of the
I got contacted by a management company
didn't even know that they existed and
they came round and they said we can we
can manage your house for you if you
want for a failure and I was like yeah
so happened so how much do you make off
that now now you've got a property
because I'm assuming now you don't do
anything with that
no it's a it's a 3-bedroom if you turn
into a more before bedroom because the
front reception room works where as well
as a bedroom yeah and you get serviced
combination out relation I'm full-time
and yeah I'm averaging 2,000 a month
after management fees and then I drilled
the fees to that sort of right or I
bills are more getting about 600 a month
so hold on hold on this this this is
where it gets rich so you bought this
real rubbish house mm-hmm
we've no survey it was terrible yeah you
pull all your money back out for the
refurb McNally you're making two
thousand pound profit about 40,000
profit a month yeah as I said my
mortgage is getting paid so your return
on investment on that is infinite yeah
so if I'll actually feel pretty much for
that one one first property you know
which is gonna fly us so from that from
reading from from reading a book
promoting you to go into the free event
you have been on the deal phonies
driving down through as well I've been
on the tear home since yeah but you've
done one it's going very well and what
did people say because obviously when
you were going through the very dark
pattern you when you when everything was
going wrong in February 2018 what will
your family and friends say to you about
the property that you bought you know
were they're saying that you're a via my
mom I remember coming around just before
Christmas and when I realized that the
dunk it was actually needed to be
properly sorted and then the dry rot and
then the leak in a really was like deck
and walking
or by you do this this is great this is
not great investment you know and I was
like yeah
all right besides like second down
myself you know definitely I didn't know
that I could pull my money back out of
this property or money pair the time you
know they say now now I've got people
queuing up to help me you know my mum
wants me to help her out and invested up
in Liverpool or not and yeah turn around
tonight in and it's a great thing than
that so you bought this one so you
pretty much 24 grand a year profit you
pretty much violence rate least
financially free still in the military
at this point so I'm still commuting up
to to Liverpool and that and I was doing
a lot of the work of my towards the end
I was doing a lot work on the house of
myself to cut cops down Malindi so I
assumed you'd left a minute earlier so
when did you leave the military there I
actually left the military in October
just gone to two months per working
full-time time in the wrong range Monday
to Friday and in Devon and then I would
commute so you did all this in your
spare time
yeah basically trying to month you read
the graft aren't you I'm not I like to
get my hands dirty I'm not a fan of hard
work if if I see the benefits by a bit
you know what I mean and if you've got
meaning and something then yeah and I
didn't read out strikes for this one you
know what yeah so what have you done
since then so you've got this one I've
got this one and that was the first one
so yeah I did inherit a little bit from
my dad and obviously I pulled the money
but cast even have invested that wisely
I have I know what you do it now I know
I'm doing I still went on the crash
course straight off the back of of that
course back in early summer in London
and then after that little if buckle
that I bought a property for 39 thousand
without mortgage so next time duty as
well as under the forty thousand mark
yeah in North Liverpool that one was
actually passed over from a friend of
mine who couldn't no longer go through
it because he'd just bought two flats
and under shop he was like that when I
can't I can't do this one anymore it's
going through so I don't know place
awesome three four and next door sold
for 68
four years prior so I did my maths on it
now educating myself and now in that
there was the money to be made and so I
spent a 15 on the refurb still doing a
bit bits and bobs myself how builders
out mainly like just you know and doing
tip runs and things like that because
I'm still sort of starting off and I
want it to learn about sort of
developing property what's involved in
it you know I know that I know that we
very much teach be hands-off impulsive
yeah I do believe there is a place
especially in the early days okay hands
dirty because you want you need to
understand it uh-huh
and if you're there and you know you
need to be wise to what's going on and
you know the process you have to it
forever
mm-hm but at least then when you get
other people to do it you know what it
is so for example you understand how
much of a bull lake mmm-hmm managing a
surface accommodation property is god
yeah I've been a go for a month and I
realized that I I've got so much respect
for my management company oh yeah that
dude like 11 o'clock we had one of the
Pens poke him and and I'm a Saturday
night and they went round there you know
they sort out I don't you know and
little things like that you can put you
can project that's good I think it's
good to get a bit a bit hands-on so I
don't that's a bad thing so this one so
you bought it for 39 yeah 15 grand on it
and the refracts at 54 yeah
and then what happened and then and the
valuer came out literally weeks ago yeah
a couple of weeks ago and they went
round and the first thing I did make him
make him a cup of coffee yeah you know
what's this yeah a new roof from the
kitchen plaster in their new brand new
kitchen brand new bar food you know just
things work that I think my family the
lenders when they come around you've got
I can't do the job for them put it in
solid stone and but you still obviously
got to tell them what you've done I've
taken a few pictures of my my I'm not a
pal it was like yeah what
was like like the kitchen by the
salesman it's just selling the work
you've done
yeah yes to be asked to come to a
certain extent and he was actually
active military himself so we got a bit
of a rapport going and go on you know
tell me is you pulling money I pull I
pulled all but three grand out it came
back at seventy thousand so I'm a see
75% of I was 52 yeah and a half pretty
much full the only money out you know
somewhere money back out and and that
will work that will go all day long as
they abide to let yeah but some tenants
lined out five hundred a month will be
rented out for I'm a mortgage on that
would be about 170 180 mm so it's three
320 in in that just which is great and
then the last the last thing that I've
been doing and after the DfE who skips
over that that's brilliant
yeah just bought them out for free yes
yeah carry on the last deal that I did
off the back of the DFA yeah great
couple of days and damnit your offices
Morgan Hampton yeah and obviously
they're the red to si is it's a real
sort of buzzing me in the industry at
the moment and there's obviously people
making making great great money out of
it
so I thought yeah I've got a bit of time
now between now and Christmas maybe
actually trying to get myself yes and I
picked up one right next to unfilled
football stadium in Liverpool a brand
new house land land alone owns outright
you know and he's a London owner the
game show at the rent on it and got them
down a bit so the rent on that seven
hundred a month full permission to do
serviced accommodation I carried out the
lease the furniture on this one was in
the fourth position where I had a little
bit of money and the leasing for a full
bed he was coming out
really mega hi so I shopped around using
places like Facebook marketplace to get
brand new beds
yeah bnm from art my pictures for the
walls yeah yeah a bit of wall that go
all our themes with the walls I had like
different different colors for each
rooms and yeah
it went like a bit on Airbnb on the
floor for December and this is the first
month we've got the Christmas month I
think all about 900 in profit for
December for that for that one property
amazed as I so passively yes actively
will you do to off that not you doing
and then you've got your single that
you've for over three maybe 40 grand a
year would you guess yeah have a memory
yeah I've got so think in 10 months ago
mmm-hmm you I've got no money you can
create cards are maxed out you I left
with this unlivable house that you're
planning on living in and you in a
really dark place where everyone your
friends if I may turn around go in your
any idea and that and then 10 months
later you're passively earning 40,000
pounds from property and you've got
money in the bank as well yeah what yeah
yeah yeah pull out full-time in property
now yeah machina nice it's such an
inspirational amazing story so you love
it
it could have gotten it could have gone
the other way Labor's you know if if I
hadn't it would never live away because
it did go the other way
yeah oh yeah but you fought your way out
of it because you you work hard you're a
grafter and you know when to educate
yourself and you do it and you take
action mmm-hmm so it could go the other
way I wish I'd educated myself prior to
to a certain extent yeah it would have
slavery a lot of hassle yeah too late
saved a lot of stress education is is
key must've leaked and you know low load
loads coming on on the course is through
class course it does blow your minds and
no like the pet that's when the petty
properly dropped is you know nothing
yeah and that how deep other people are
watching this now might wanna get in
touch to view them and adventure offer
for you
so it will literally be a case of going
on there some leads Facebook group you
can you can search my name Declan Archer
drop me a message I'm currently looking
for my next deal might have something
going through the vApp up in in Wigan
not with off plan to give that you know
and I was saying and saying earlier I've
not felt comfortable in property over
that's all in the last yeah yeah they
truly and one of the things that Samuel
says is get comfortable being being
uncomfortable and it is so true I've
potentially doing off a bit by refurb
refinance but why not go I will have
done that what's the next step yeah and
the next logical step is you know he's
in bridging for a bigger deal a joint
venture with someone and I'm just
getting project managers in place for
for a conversion you know or or for a
build even why not keep on educating
yourself yang part yeah you don't even
what what one big what one big tip would
you give to people because for your year
would you have believed it if back in
February I spoken to our league on debt
there in December you're gonna be
passively only forty thousand pounds a
month your property is gonna be bringing
in that property alone that you've
bought right out and William two
thousand Panama's you gonna have another
few as well would you really no chance
that's not bad but so what tip would you
because the market people out there
watching this that are in a situation
like you were in right now so what
inspirate what we're gonna obviously
within your story yeah which is
Bridgeton itself what what what would
you say my mindset
positive mindset we keep going you'd
like I think mindset is key you know if
you're a slightly negative person you
know just try to be a bit more positive
work through it you know you're gonna
get tested in property you're not going
to be comfortable if you're going into
the prop your first property jail and
you've got yeah that's fine it's easier
than I met loads of money and you're not
a little bit uncomfortable about it
something seriously wrong really I think
personally you know you need to put
yourself out of your comfort zone to get
where you want to be in property this is
just from my experience so far I mean
yes ten years in the Royal Marines out
help me
and was it uncomfortable many times in
my previous previous job and that did
help me and that helped me get me free
back with the right help in the right
guidance and that positive mindset you
know anyone can do it honestly you know
but definitely absolute pleasure having
you on the show such an inspirational
story we've got the winners on Wednesday
every single Wednesday so don't forget
to tune in again next week I hope you
guys are inspired by that and all don't
forget to subscribe we'll see you soon
my name is Samuel Leeds thank you for
watching winners on a Wednesday every
single week we interview a success
students for your inspiration you can
watch more right here on the playlist as
a whole playlist of them but what you'll
notice is every single winner on a
Wednesday always starts with them coming
to my two day crash course so if you
would like to be a winner on a Wednesday
literally come on my crash course and
who knows in three months time you could
be here in my offices on this show as a
winner on a Wednesday so get yourself
booked on the crash course watch more
have fun I'll see you next week